alan sills had the conference call today
with the commissioner
roger goodell insists that the nfl can
safely and responsibly complete the
season
i
i i yeah
can
will is the other issue and i think
for as long as you are sending players
and coaches out in the community
every day
and as long as the numbers continue to
go up and up and up in the community
that's where you run the risk of not
just one or two guys testing positive
inevitably but five or six or seven all
at once and then anyone they're in
contact with being knocked out on the
covet 19 reserve list you're gonna have
more situations like we saw with the
denver broncos where rosters are
decimated but i guess the nfl looks at
and says hey
there's 53 guys on the
active roster 16 on the practice squad
that could be called up at any time up
to 90 minutes before kickoff
should be more than enough and i don't
know what the critical mass is i don't
know how many guys have to be out before
a team just can't play but some would
say hey as long as you got 11 you're
good to go right in basketball if if
they've only got five guys and one fouls
out they play with four so not that the
nfl would ever come to 10 guys on the
field but i just
sense that they are not going to worry
about that they expect guys to be ready
to play if they're not on the covet 19
reserve list they expect teams to be
ready to play and they're going to play
these games
yeah mike i was on the call and that was
my big takeaway from it and roger
goodell said that you know we're gonna
make these medical decisions over
competitive reasons over business
interest and this is what we're gonna do
when we're going to roll and alan sill
said look when a player tests positive
we don't consider him a player we don't
consider what position he plays at that
point he's a patient and they go into
the high risk they don't care what the
position are if you look at what
colleges are doing you know they have
these certain numbers that you were
talking about that if they don't have
a quarterback if they don't have x
number of offensive linemen if they
don't have x number of defensive linemen
i think those are the three positions
and they say we're not going to play and
and if we don't have x number of total
players we're not going to play and
roger goodell said look we changed all
the rules
the rosters are the practice squads are
bigger you can call those guys up we did
this for a reason we don't care that you
don't have a position group go play the
game we don't care what positions they
are we're going to get these games in
and you're going to have to play if you
have enough players to put on the field
and we've seen that we've seen that
repeatedly with several teams we've seen
it with the 49ers we earlier this year
against the packers we've seen it with
the broncos with no quarterbacks and
we're seeing it today with the ravens
with what they're throwing out in the
field so that's exactly it mike they're
going to play the games it doesn't
matter we don't know what that total
number is maybe there's a total number
but goodness sakes i mean the ravens
still have 16 players on the coveted
list and they're playing this game so
i'm not sure how high the number goes
and for anyone out there who for some
reason is only watching us and not
monitoring the game they are now at
halftime the steelers lead 12 to seven
the ravens
threw the ball into the end zone luke
wilson dropped what could have been a
touchdown pass as time expired in the
first half so 12-7 no risk get no
biscuit they risked that they got no
biscuit at the end of the half 12-7 the
steelers lead the postseason bubble
concept has been kicked around from time
to time and as i understand it because
we were doing football pod in america so
i missed the start of the conference
call and i didn't want to jump on late
and make that beep beep sound and
distract everybody uh the commissioner
initially said all options are on the
table for the post season but then said
shireen that there won't be a postseason
bubble and here's my theory
there won't be a mandatory postseason
bubble because you won't need a
mandatory postseason bubble because the
teams that are still alive in the
postseason will do a voluntary bubble
and the team leaders the players the
quarterbacks the defensive leaders will
all put the squeeze on the other players
to volunteer to stay in a hotel for the
balance of the season this all gets back
to collective bargaining that is at the
core of this the league doesn't want to
have to go to the union and ask for
permission to make mandatory hotel stays
because the union will say wait a minute
you're asking for a lot here you're
asking to take guys away from their
families for extended periods of time
even if it's a postseason you're
knocking out guys for the two super bowl
teams for a month from their family life
so
the union would want something
justifiably so it's part of the
collective bargaining arrangement the
league doesn't want to give anything up
and some would say maybe they should the
league doesn't want to so they're taking
a risk here that some players will
choose not to voluntarily bubble and
that could potentially screw things up
but the attitude will be the same that
it was all year long hey if you're
positive
you're down someone else is up go play
the games
mike they really talked in circles on
this issue you know at the beginning you
know goodell did say all things are on
the table and then he said we're not
going he said it depends on what kind of
bubble you're talking about and what he
said they're not definitely going to do
is going to have a bubble like baseball
did where they put all teams at one site
and that makes perfect sense i mean
you're not going to have that many teams
at one site in the nfl i i get that but
i don't think they have definitely ruled
out having bubbles in individual cities
local bubbles and as you said even if
this isn't something that they do
league-wide we're gonna see teams do it
we saw the cowboys were among the teams
the saints uh in the training camp do
this and they had sort of the voluntary
bubbles where the team leader said hey
this is what we're gonna do we're gonna
go stay in a hotel and we're going to
come out and we're just going to be on
the field for training camp and that's
it we're not going home and i definitely
think you're going to see that in the
postseason i think one question that
hasn't been asked yet mike what if we
have a situation like the ravens in the
postseason
like how far are we gonna kick the can
down with it with a game where you're
delaying the next week's set of games
that will be curious to me but if you
have these local bubbles i think that
you have less of a chance to do that
less of a chance to have the big covet
outbreak where you are having to push a
game back for almost a week frankly
they're supposed to play thanksgiving
night
yeah six days of a delay for this game
and that would wreak havoc on the
postseason schedule it would delay
everyone and the prospect of a week 18
already creates the possibility that the
one seeds in the two conferences will go
three weeks between playing games and uh
the 49ers right now
have a situation that could become a
test case for a localized bubble they're
in arizona they're going to stay in
arizona and there are coaches out there
who are envious of what the 49ers have
fallen into because i know from talking
to some coaches they would much rather
be away from home in a hotel locked down
because then they don't have to worry
about guys getting exposed to the virus
away from the team and that's exactly
what the 49ers will be doing everyone
together for the foreseeable future
although i guess there's a possibility
guys can bring their families down get
an airbnb and go back and forth as if
they're temporarily living in arizona i
don't know how many guys are going to do
that i doubt the whole team would do
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports